i saw a video of you talking to
charles isbell about westworld the tv
series
you guys were doing kind of thing where
you're watching new things together but
let's
rewind back is there a sci-fi movie
or book or shows that you
that was profound that had an impact on
you philosophically or just like
specifically something you enjoyed
nerding out about
yeah interesting i think a lot of us
have been inspired by robots in movies
the one that i really like is uh
there's a movie called robot and frank
which i think is really interesting
because it's very near-term
future where uh robots are being
deployed as
uh helpers in people's homes and it was
it was
and we don't know how to make robots
like that at this point but it seemed
very plausible it seemed very
realistic or imaginable and i thought
that was really cool because
they they're awkward they do funny
things it raised some interesting issues
but
it seemed like something that would
ultimately be helpful and good if we
could do it right
yeah he was an older cranky gentleman
right he was an older cranky
uh jewel thief yeah it's kind of funny
little
thing which is you know he's a dual
thief and so he
pulls the robot into his life which is
like
which is something you could imagine
taking
a home robotics thing and pulling into
whatever
quirky thing that's involved in your
this is meaningful to you yeah
exactly so yeah and i think i think from
that perspective i mean not all of us
are jewel thieves and so when we bring
our robots into
yourself yeah uh it explains a lot about
this apartment actually
but no the idea that that people should
have the ability to
you know make this technology their own
that that it becomes part of their lives
and and i think that's
it's hard for us as technologists to
make that kind of technology it's easier
to mold people
into what we need them to be and um just
that opposite vision i think is really
inspiring
and then there's a anthropomorphization
where we project
certain things on them because i think
the robot was kind of dumb
but i have a bunch of roombas that play
with and they you you immediately
project
stuff onto them much greater level of
intelligence we'll probably do that with
each other too
much much greater much greater degree of
compass that's right one of the things
we're learning from ai
is where we are smart and where we are
not smart yeah
you